[Music]
it's not enough for CBS deals this morning we
have four items that may help make your day a
little easier and could help you get a jump on
those holiday deals with gifts for your loved
ones all at exclusive low prices to start shopping
you can scan the QR code on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Sukanya Krishnan
joins us with more it is good to see you nice
to see you Jeff we've got a lot of stuff here
it is holiday crunch time so it's time to get
to business and get to shopping what's first
all right so I love this this is called she's
birdie and this is a protective device that you
can carry on you this is something that you can
give it's a peace of mind it doesn't look like a
lot but boy it's small and mighty are you ready
to open this really quickly uh tell the audio
guy uh just to one second you see what this is
130 decibels um it's got a strobe light it grabs
attention when you need attention I think this is
perfect for somebody who works the overnight shift
you just pull the pin 130 decibels you see right
there it sounds the alarm this is perfect for
the kid who's going to school this is perfect
for a person who is actually working an overnight
shift a parent my mom actually fell in a parking
lot and she had this and she was able to pull
the pin and get attention when she needed how
much is this one so we're looking at 30 off we're
looking at under 20. 19.99 I think this is the
perfect stocking stuffer so get to your QR code
and let's do this okay next all right we can't
look as gorgeous as you I got wrinkles we've
got wrinkles we've all got problems thank you
um so this is perfect this is FDA approved it's a
little silicon peel right here um so this is made
in the United States and this is just for your
under eye you put something like this so we've got
it for your mouth your under eye your decollete
and this is called wrinkle sminkel just basically
what it says it's peel press and remove you can
see the person right there putting it underneath
their eye their decollete you wash your skin you
put it on and you just let the magic work and the
deal right now that we have going on anywhere from
nine to thirty five dollars a savings of 35 so I
think this is a perfect gift to give somebody
who doesn't necessarily take care of themselves
but you want them to take care of themselves or
it's a gift you can buy for yourself for a little
self-care Sunday moments knock out those wrinkles
what's next knock out their wrinkles and cook at
the same time all right this is an award-winning
gift right here it's called pixicaid pets and
you're thinking what's in this little box it's
got everything the parent would love and their
kid can use their devices it's stem learning
right here and inside this little book if I can
open this up and not drive the cameraman too crazy
you've got these little sheets so your kid gets to
create right here with the markers that are also
in the kit right here they get to create a pet
they download the app and the pet actually comes
to life virtually you could put stickers on it see
right right there they can create an arcade system
it is quite fantastic so download the app this is
an award-winning situation and we're looking at
under 15 40 off 40 off this is something for the
grandparents to have when everybody comes home
this is something for you to have as a stocking
stuffer or just something that you can give
somebody that you love a neighbor let me drive
the cameraman crazy all the time okay don't worry
about it I'm sorry about that I'm fidgeting around
but you know pets is one of those things that the
kids are going to want to get their hands into
listen we're moving from virtual pets to how about
your real pets do you have a dog out there I have
a fur baby that I love but this is a GPS tracking
device and there's lots of tracking devices that
are out there but this is actually under a hundred
dollars I'm going to tell you the price in just a
minute but this tracking device does so much more
it actually tells the vitals of your dog how much
they ate how much they ran how much they walk it
also can teach them tricks because it has that
clicker that's built in to this little device
which then attaches on their collar I'm going
to give you the deal right now we're looking at
89.99 we're talking about 60 off Suki was nice
to meet you it was really nice to meet you John
I'm just gonna say that happy holidays a lot tall
ER companies to get these deals
to buy anything you saw today scan
that QR code on your screen or you
can head once again to cbsdeals.com